Fotis Doulos is in critical condition
this morning after attempting suicide
Doulos is charged with kidnapping and
killing his estranged wife at their
connecticut home last May and this was
the scene yesterday as first responders
worked to save his life after finding
him unconscious in his garage du Louis
then unloaded or was then unloaded on to
an ambulance for transport to a nearby
hospital and has since been moved to New
York mola legi is outside the hospital
where he's being treated now mola good
morning strange development here what do
we know oh yeah good morning Tony do
Lowe's is being treated here at Jacobi
Medical Center for carbon monoxide
poisoning meanwhile investigators are
still going through the scene at his
Connecticut home they wouldn't confirm
to us yesterday whether he left a note
in this apparent suicide attempt now as
we know as you mentioned Doulos and his
ex-girlfriend are charged in the alleged
murder of his estranged wife Jennifer
both the suspects are out on bail Fotis
Doulos landed at this New York City
Hospital Tuesday afternoon after
officers found him unresponsive sitting
in his running vehicle in the garage of
his Farmington Connecticut home police
were sent to check on Doulos after he
failed to show up for a bond hearing
that could have sent him back to jail
pending trial for the alleged murder of
his wife when officers responded they
could see through a window that Mister
dillos was sitting in his vehicle and he
had obvious signs of medical distress
drones flying above his home captured
footage of officers trying to revive the
52 year old they performed CPR for more
than 10 minutes Doulos was rushed to u
con health before being transferred via
medical helicopter to New York City
doctors say he could suffer permanent
damage once the heart has been damaged
once the brain has been without enough
oxygen for too long there can be
irreversible symptoms doulos was under
house arrest awaiting trial for the
alleged murder of his wife Jennifer who
disappeared in May after taking her five
children to school officers have
investigated for months but have yet to
find her body a fact the defense plans
on highlighting at the trial we
categorically deny that Mister dillos
had any involvement
in the disappearance of his wife
Jennifer and we defy the state to prove
that she is in fact dead do Llosa's
former girlfriend Michelle true CONUS
and his former attorney Kent Melanie
were also arrested both are charged with
conspiracy to commit murder for
allegedly helping doulos cover up the
suspected crime Melanie's lawyers says
the state does not have enough evidence
now if do Lowe's does suffer some sort
of permanent health damage that could
ultimately impact his trial later this
year if he has deemed unable to
participate in his own defense of course
he is facing life in prison on this
murder charge he has insisted in his
innocence meanwhile Anthony the couple's
five children are in the care of
Jennifer's mother you know another twist
and in this already tragic story Imola
thank you